Johnathan's with us in San Francisco hi
Jonathan welcome to Dave Ramsey show hey
how you doing today better than I
deserve
what's up well Colin today with a quick
question my wife and I have so just
briefly she's got an opportunity to work
closer to home and we're trying to just
tackle the situation seeing what's
better fit for our new family understand
so right now financially speaking she's
thinking about seventy five thousand a
year and with this new opportunity that
we have she'd likely take a pay cut of
anywhere from sixty to sixty five
thousand a year she currently commutes
about an hour and a half daily in this
one direction
listen donate so she's a financial
manager and there's no financial
managers closer than an hour and a half
away why in the world would a 65 that's
a 90 percent pay cut mm-hmm
Tony works between 60 and 65 thousand
for the nearest one in town and then
there's no homework so her deposition
she works
I'm so confused did you say she makes
seventy five now and she'd be making 65
at the new place yes oh why don't you
miss you got a cut of 65,000 it was
gonna go down to town and I'm like good
lord okay what she wanted Burger King I
didn't know what was going on okay okay
I'm catching on now so a ten thousand
dollar pay cut but is she in a position
where she's gonna grow a book of
business and her pay will come back
overtime so there is a potential for
things like bonuses and you know raises
throughout the years if she sees with
the company we're just more concerned
with the budgeting aspect obviously it's
going to mess the numbers right now and
you're probably spending all most of the
difference in an hour and a half drive
every day yeah we calculated about rough
about three thousand years just in fuel
that's not even considering maintenance
things like that yeah and destruction of
value of the car exactly so this cars
gone down like
Rock I mean it's called on your 10 grand
for her to commute on hour and a half
it's just a mechanic's standpoint I mean
being at a fellow car lover like
yourself I hate seeing down that road
every day so yeah I'm just trying to see
what we can possibly do and what you
what your two cents are in regards to oh
I would take the job I would take the
job I'm because I don't I think cash
flow might tighten up a little bit more
but overall over the period of a year or
two or three you know the transition in
one car to another over time and that
kind of thing
you're not losing money over a period of
five years now your cash flow man you
see what I'm saying
because you're not experiencing cash
flow bite from your car going down in
value from an hour and a half commute
but it is going down in value faster
than it will be if she lives close to
home plus you'll have your wife back oh
yes I'm definitely taking this job I'm
for a 10k pay cut and you got the
opportunity to work and do other stuff
and you know you could pick up an extra
job occasionally and fill in a whole lot
of this it's and share her income will
come up because she's a better gonna be
a better person she's not living in a
car 3 hours a day oh yes I'm taking this
job
[Music]